it's really funny cuz whenever we do get
together it's just like hsm reunions
[Music]
High School Musical turns 10 On January
20th and et was with Ashley Tisdale just
before Disney broke the news about the
televised reunion coming our way I just
love that we all still love each other
and love hanging out with each other and
have that connection you know it's a
very special moment in our life and
going through that was it wasn't typical
because you know nobody thought it was
going to be as successful as it was and
it was really purely because of the fans
that it was that successful and the fact
that they've supported us throughout all
these years it's been amazing
Sharpay would be today um that's a good
question on Broadway or like has done
Broadway and it's just like maybe she's
done like 10 Broadway shows at this
point I have no idea and she's just like
a full-on diva 5 6 7
we put Ashley in the ultimate HSM hot
seat we want to play a quick High School
Musical game with you gosh I'm so
nervous
called high school music well graduation
superlatives okay are you ready most
likely to win an Oscar think like Zach's
on the road to winning Oscar baby most
likely to have kids first don't say me
that's enough let's not maybe not having
kids anytime soon I don't know I really
don't know maybe money Monique for sure
because she's like been married for a
while she's older she's gonna hate me
that's a gone Monique oh no most likely
to coordinate a reunion I feel like I'm
definitely a coordinator so maybe you
know I love getting everybody together I
like to do is that kind of cool like
slumber parties with my cast and stuff
so I probably make most likely to binge
watch oh definitely and I will admit
that
you